hello everybody I'm back
with observation Duty I
I'm gonna beat this and not only am I
going to beat this
but then for some reason I'm then gonna
go to the bank
I don't know why
but I'm gonna do that
I don't know why I'm back for another
one but I know I know what all of the
things are in this I think anyway I
think I remember not 100 sure
but I'm pretty sure I remember them so
if I can just get through the goddamn
day
I'll be I've forgotten
I've forgotten everything uh it wasn't
the light switches that was not a part
of it
was an eyeball up there oh the heater
the chair can disappear the painting can
change uh
uh there's always something in the
bathroom I don't know
either way I'm pretty sure I can beat it
I have full confidence in myself and I
like my odds
I don't like my odds
oh no
oh God
thank you for holding on a little longer
thank you for uh me holding on a little
longer and you going a little sooner
and I gotta remember the outside thing
if the outside thing gets me again I'm
going to lose my mind I'm gonna throw my
computer out of the window
oh God I don't remember
either I'm missing something or it just
hasn't happened yet which
probably is true
oh no
oh no how
how
have I forgotten I've forgotten
something haven't I oh no oh no
oh oh hey
thank you
thank you very much I know it starts
slow so I'm probably freaking myself out
more than I need to but I'm I just can't
lose again I just I just can't lose
again guys I don't know if I can
emotionally take it if I lose again
there's nothing outside chairs are fine
signs fine pictures are fine
chairs are fine
bottle is okay
rug is okay sign is fine that's fine
everything's fine here
well this is strange
head
uh head uh head uh head da head duh
foreign
starts slow
I get ahead of myself thinking that it's
gonna Rush him at me
not necessarily true
sometimes it's very procedural
by now you guys know all of the things
that can be wrong in this if you don't
you're less observant than I am which is
an accomplishment all of men involve
itself
um not something we all should be proud
of but it's just something that can
happen
oh hello
bedroom
the painting up there if you didn't see
it is different very different
all right
I think I've been on top of them
unless there's something extremely
subtle which there always could be
but everything seems to be in order
nothing's outside the plants are missing
the vas is there pillows are there
everything there chairs are in the right
place rug is there trash can is there
nothing outside nothing outside
chairs are there sign is there paintings
are fine paintings are fine bottles fine
chairs are fine
this rug is fine everything is fine here
everything is fine here no eyeballs
nothing weird here
nothing strange
plants are fine objects are fine nothing
outside
everything good
it's about time for another one
another one that I might be missing
oh my God don't do this to me
God there's one there and I'm not seeing
it
uh
ah
what am I not seeing what am I not
seeing
huh
how am I not seeing anything
this is impossible how am I not seeing
anything
's fine here this is all the same
everything's fine
oh that painting that painting in the
back there that painting uh living room
oh but if uh uh there must be something
else there must be something else that
I'm missing there's no way in that time
frame that it would have just been one
more maybe it would have been I don't
know it just seems to me
like I might be missing one I'd rather
err on the thought that I am
the not and miss something but I just
don't remember of anything else it could
possibly be
different this is the same
this is the same
the signage is the same that painting is
the same that painting is the same
toilet seat is up no heads that's all
the same
that I just fixed this
rug is there trash can chairs no head
uh-huh
uh-huh oh head head head head head head
head
toilet head toilet just gotta remember
the outside thing I just have to
remember the outside thing if it's
outside I report it as outside period
there is no other way
okay
that desk is different that's different
that's very different
very different and it wasn't outside it
was not outside so if I remember things
that aren't outside I'm fine
I'm missing one
I know it
I feel it
oh my God oh my God hallway oh my God oh
my God oh my God oh my
[Applause]
oh my
what in the hell was that
how am I still finding new things
okay well that's something
not sure why that was something but that
sure was something in reality there
aren't that many things that change in
each room it's just that there are so
many other details that you don't know
what it is you need to watch
that's what makes it difficult
it's just this constant hunting for
something that might not even be there
or my never move but there's a certain
amount of logic to it
like chairs seem to be a common theme to
change
it usually is something that might
involve some rearrangement of objects
especially if they're set up like this
in a way that would make it apparent
that something like that would change
well that changed that subtle that was
subtle it was always three white cups on
the right I do know that
and it's not outside if it's outside
declared is outside
oh frick
okay that's good halfway there halfway
there
easy
very easy
no problem
no problemo
ah
there was a there was a a chandelier
there was a
yeah that thing whatever you would call
that there's a light
I wasn't there anymore
okay
I think it's starting to accelerate
which is fine
I can deal
I generally know I make this sweep like
up and down usually in all these rooms I
sweep up and I sweep down
[Music]
this General sweep is like the pattern
of all these you go you kind of go along
the outer walls of the room and that'll
give you an idea
of a path
the chair is missing in the hallway far
chair missing yeah if you just trace the
wall that's probably like the best way
to approach this is just trying to trace
the wall
so that you catch all the corners of the
room
and your eye will go to somewhere
that'll
be different and then when your sweep is
interrupted because your subconscious
tells you something is off
that's
that's when you can
start to rely on your instincts because
you know visually
that something was not there or is there
because you establish a pattern of
looking it so you kind of create I'm
this is just me guessing and talking to
fill space you create this expected
routine when you move and therefore it's
easier to memorize that pattern instead
of memorizing everything individually
I'm missing one
I've got to be missing something
's missing
oh I'm missing something
oh oh oh oh whoa whoa whoa there uh uh
something's missing right here there was
like a radio
it's giving me the subtle ones
extremely subtle ones bottle moved
maybe maybe now instead of being like
faster it's now two anomalies appear at
once or something like that
because that I would have noticed that
on the past sweep
for sure yeah I still don't know exactly
how it works in terms of establishing an
anomaly but at the very least I was able
to catch those two back to back which is
great
oh rug is missing in the kitchen rugs
missing
good good good good
four four o'clock doing so damn good
doing so damn good
so good
I just gotta remember outside outside
exists outside is its own concept
outside is a concept and it exists oh my
God God oh my God oh my God oh my God oh
my God I don't want to even look at you
that was not outside I didn't even think
about outside
because all the a lot of the creatures
are outside so don't look at if it's
outside it's outside I'm gonna forget it
I'm gonna forget it I know I am
I know I'm gonna forget it
I know that
I accept that about well painting
painting in the kitchen is different
it's accelerating it's definitely
accelerating
oh do not whisper in my ear
especially if you're not actually an
anomaly
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa that did not that was a different
color
that was a different color towel there
oh
okay 4 30 just about
oh that ain't right
that ain't right that's not right there
and that's not an outside thing that's
inside leads to the outside but I bet
it's inside
okay better be yeah can't you can't
scream me with that
oh this carpet is different
that ain't right
this is all the same the rug is there
the trash can's there
everything's here that light's there
that's there
the signs the same pictures are the same
chair the same bottles the same cups are
the same
oh one of my signs the same
carpet's good
uh I feel like something might be
missing from here but I don't know no
radiator chairs are there everything's
fine
what am I missing
oh no
no no no these are fine
what am I missing
no I'm so close don't do this to me
there's nothing outside
everything's fine
everything's the same
oh bad bad bad bad bad bad is different
bed is completely different one last
hour okay one more hour I get this
remember outside outside is a thing if
if I if I remember that outside is a
thing nothing can get me
nothing could possibly get me
chairs there
painting's fine
's fine
bathroom is fine
fine
that's the same all the same
oh why do I feel like something I always
had I think that was the same
this is fine nothing outside okay
outside outside it's outside not kitchen
it's outside
outside 508
almost there
good
you switched I know you switched
I know that
outside
I think there
I think I might be getting close to in
the clear
good
hi parlor man stop go don't do it
[Music]
don't
don't do it
[Music]
don't like you don't like you
I don't know what it is about the house
level that makes me just feel like I am
incapable
of keeping these things in my mind
in reality I don't think that this is
all that much more complicated than say
the supermarket the supermarket had tons
of stuff like just
oodles and noodles of stuff that I did
not see at all
truly
so many things and yet
I think I might have just lucked out
when it came to it
oh my god oh
all right thank you for that
I think there's something else about
like going at it at a certain speed
there was this desire to like look at
everything instead of just trying to get
the sense of normalcy first because
that's what I didn't do in this level is
I did I didn't try to like go quickly
through to see what everything was when
it was normal because it does take time
for the first anomaly to appear I think
I don't know for sure but maybe and that
like completely derailed me from ever
being able to establish like a Baseline
and the Baseline is essential to getting
the ability to spot a difference
you just gotta have the Baseline with a
quick scan
so that you can train yourself to not
hang around I think this is all just me
talking out my ass I don't actually know
what I'm talking about here I'm just
guessing
probably put a big probably on
everything I say huge is probably
big old probableye
speaking of probably I am whoa whoa
almost missed that a little painting
hello I think I won this
easy
done
[Music]
yes yes
[Applause]
finally I did that I did that
okay
um however that being said
25 anomalies not bad go again why would
anybody go again
I do remember that yeah
after this well the barrel was formed
all right all right thanks
I don't know why
but I'm going into the bank
I don't know why look guys I don't know
why but I'm gonna try to apply what I
just did by doing quick looky-loos of
everything so that I can get a Baseline
okay
well yeah yeah I know I know I know
try to get that Baseline in those
paintings are creepy but I'm assuming
that's normal
oh God why you gotta have paintings like
that why does that have to be like that
zap zubity Bop see like what is that
painting what is that supposed to be
what is that guy supposed to be
[Music]
it's back to where it was
looks the same
looks the same oh it's so dark down
there I might have to turn up the
brightness on this one just because it's
like really dark okay that's better
I'm assuming I'm just gonna lose this
first one because I don't know how I
would see
a difference right away
that that Lobby one is going to be the
biggest problem I bet because they just
it's so huge
these other ones are actually fairly
contained it's not bad so there's not
that many things that could change like
this one there's not much here
this one has quite a bit
if there's an anomaly here already I
don't know
if I would ever see it
just gonna safety do one here
it's probably wrong but I'm assuming I'm
gonna fail this first try anyway
and no anomalies there that was normal
whatever was in there it was perfectly
normal
oh
oh oh
[Music]
well it's not really an anomaly someone
just wanted some coffee which I can
understand and respect so that was
probably the second anomaly I'm willing
to bet that there was already one
I'm willing to bet that that painting is
actually normal probably
just fix this one probably not happening
again there
that's the same I got a horn in on like
details that are probably
the movable ones if there's something
that's too in Shadow I'm willing to bet
that it's not going to be there probably
the things on top of the shelves here
can change
the paintings are always an option
definitely chairs are an option
oh don't laugh at me
oh oh whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa these were parallel these were
pairs these were matched pairs
oh my God oh my God
it's the Baseline
you get the bass line in then
immediately what's wrong will jump out
at you
what's in there wasn't there a trash can
was there no there wasn't there was I
can't remember I'm not gonna dwell on it
four there's four gold bars
there's pairs there nothing really on
the upper balcony besides that and a
plan over there
uh keys on the left here
uh
there's a trash can here
bench chairs
counting painting in the back
as it was I think so
I think so
that was that always
yeah that yeah yeah yeah yeah
see now I'm starting to question
everything now I'm getting to that point
where it's like well everything looks
exactly as it always has been this key
there that's fine I know I'm missing an
anomaly I just I don't know what it is
yet though
my fix to this one it's probably not
here again
this looks all the same
I'm gonna get the alert soon I know it I
think there was a trash can here
I'm pretty sure
I'm pretty sure there was a trash can
there unless it's not likely to put
another anomaly where I had another
anomaly especially in the beginning
phase
damn it Frick off rack I'm dead uh I
knew that I knew that was gonna happen I
knew I was gonna lose that's totally
fine all the computers off except for
that one was that computer always on
I know I know
I know this all looks the same unless it
wasn't always a plant in a box I might
have gotten to the point where it's
already starting to change and I'm just
an idiot but whatever it's fine
frick frick
frick
[Music]
frock
oh
I looked here
this one is so simple it's probably
deceptively simple there's probably
something else going on here that I'm
not seeing ah
oh I just gotta guess I gotta guess
because i'm boned either way uh uh uh
there wasn't much in here right crap
crap crap crap
it's fine I need to get a better bass
line anyway two anomalies it's better
than my last try it's better than the
must try
so I just gotta quickly go in here and
look at everything again okay I don't
know anything different from here this
the desk is definitely the same these
paintings look the same everything looks
the same yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
there was a ah I don't I think this
plant was missing I'm pretty sure that
plant was missing okay all right there
was no trash can here these paintings
are the same these desks are simple that
one is very simple that painting is the
same only this computer's on
there is a trash can there that painting
is the same it was a box and plant plant
here I gotta watch for the plants the
plants definitely go
plants definitely or something
there's two stacks of money four gold
bars three right there
okay good
this is the equal pairs of chairs two
lights
this is the same two chairs there
painting plant two chairs
bench baby baby other thing coffee
machine was a thing
what was the other
I don't even know what the other anomaly
I recorded was I don't even remember I
think it might have been something more
obvious
first anomaly should be there it should
just be one well that's different that's
a different baby there was two babies it
was not like that that's not the
nightmare that I saw
that is definitely not the nightmare
that I saw
okay okay
it was a different nightmare it's
similar nightmares but different
nightmare
was different that's the same nightmare
okay that was probably the first one so
everything else was Baseline everything
else was as it
yeah was as it was for to sex money
painting
chairs
uh slip and slide
bench uh plant key on left
bookshelf lights
accounting plant painting sign down
there
nightmare
water bottle water bottle machine coffee
machine
uh uh cup of coffee
oh man why is this so stressful why so
freaking cat statue Keys chair dude
two sacks of money four bars
maybe one of the doors in there will be
open
plant
chairs oh it's still dark I might turn
the brightness up a bit more plant no
trash can there was no trash can here
this white piece of paper on all of
these desks and a fan there's a fan
there
the other anomaly is here
Maybe
sometimes it's only two in the first
minute I do have to remember that
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa that other the other blinds
those were different
that was different
that yes
was there always like a baby head on
there yeah probably all right it's
working you go quick so that you can
scan each one as it should be
and then you know what's different
three former presidents probably
uh plant is there
chairs nightmare baby everything else
cup
was there something was there something
here
was there something here was there
something on the counter
or at was it didn't both of these have
white piece of paper
frick it was all these had white pieces
of paper all these did
that one only had the one I said one two
three uh for
pieces of paper on the ground there
[Music]
and
the plant gone plant gone
plant gone the plant is gone
guys the plant is gone
you you you
you
the Bars were in a line
the Bars were lined up
okay all right cheers are good
I think bench plant lights key
uh
this is the same something feels
different about this one I'm not gonna
burn an attempt on it just yet until I
get the warning but something did feel
different there these are also offset
were they always offset I don't know I
don't know
he
[Music]
uh
all I'm getting is like my I like Snap
because something yeah
something doesn't look right if you just
sweep over it make it all one big visual
noise
I guess I'm still trying to identify
like small little things here and there
that are that are that some rubbing
no no it's fine
oh that ain't right okay that's not
right okay that's definitely not right
that was something else I don't even
know what it was I don't even know what
it was but I don't mean to know what it
was because I know that it wasn't what
that was
because I'm sweeping
I don't know why
I have I have a I have another one
something seems different in here
I don't know what
something seems different
oh the lines are straight the lines are
more straight
I didn't even notice that
oh my God oh my God I'm ascending I'm
evolving
I'm evolving
I feel like something's missing here but
it's not like if it's there's a
difference between my gut reaction
saying that something is missing
and this kind of like almost chill down
my spine
when I realize that things aren't always
as they seem and I gotta remember what
were the things I haven't reported
anything in here there might actually be
something wrong in here and I just have
no idea
oh I know that that was the other one
the coffee oh God I forget about the
coffee
the coffee machine
I honestly I could use a cup of coffee a
little more concentration would be good
right now
hit one cup of coffee
the other person got up to make another
one but too bad for them they're not
gonna get it
uh but it's whoa hey bud wow okay hi how
are you you look like SCP-173
please go away I'm blinking too much
okay well that was a more obvious one
the paintings are always obvious so I am
honestly okay with the painting being
there because if it's a painting then I
have a pretty good chance of knowing
it's just the ones that are like already
kind of messed up
those are a bit problematic to keep an
eye on
I probably need to be looking over here
I have not been looking down there at
all there probably is something in there
did I burn an attempt there I don't know
if I did I don't think I did if if I get
an alert I am going to do that one and
I'm going to look very closely at just
to see if there's something
different let's see if I can tell what's
what's changed about it it should jump
out of me maybe we'll see
[Applause]
there was more space here before
there's a bit roomier in the vault it's
a bit roomier
sweep down
uh sweep up
sweep right sweep left
sweep down up look down here for
something
I haven't seen many like
people in this one which you know I'm
I'm okay with that that is fine with me
I'm all right with that
but at the same time
it's almost too quiet in here
oh my God
I've never been more excited in the
house I was hopeless
and I felt lost and destitute
here
no
here I feel strong I feel capable
I feel very very
impressive
I feel
uh smart and quick thinking
I feel like there's something wrong in
there though I really do
[Music]
stairs well that's weird okay good
okay well
that's interesting I still have two
chances
to
burn
and that's good
halfway there I'm halfway there oh oh
see this this feels better because the
house made me think that I was a big
dumb idiot but I got through the first
two levels just fine I swear something's
weird here I just can't tell what it is
let me let me actually
well that didn't help at all whatever
it's just dark in that one these are
still offset
oh man I shouldn't have done that I was
so used to the other way
okay whatever God damn it
now now it's all kind of like itching me
because it's like oh something different
yeah I brightened the whole scene it I
kind of ruined my instincts there
wait a minute wait a minute there were
not four chairs on that one there was a
gap right there I literally know that
that's not supposed to be there
thank you thank you very much all right
but the anomalies are probably going to
be accelerating at this point so I just
gotta keep sweeping
sweep up and down shape the room
yeah also just kind of like flipping
through with more confidence allows me
to really
get to each of them sooner
and the faster exposure kind of like
keeps it in my head a little better
whoa whoa
whoa
that painting is different
I can't tell you how
that painting was so slightly different
that painting was minusculely different
but it was staring in a different way
the expression was different
oh you too you're mirrored you are
mirrored you're not supposed to be like
that and off-centered it's like
off-centered and mirrored that was the
same thing of the other painting
oh so you're not going to be turning
into some nightmare you're just gonna be
oh so slightly different that I would
never have a hope
whoa hey painting at the back of the
hallway is different I was like some
medieval night setting I know that
because I kept looking at it because the
eye goes right to that
okay so this was normal this was fine
before that was totally fine there was
no problem with that and that was two
anomalies in a row three actually
those three anomalies in a row my God
okay I just gotta stay on my toes I
can't get lazy now because if I get lazy
now I'm gonna fail and then I'm gonna
have to do all this over again I don't
know I don't know
I really don't know if I can do it all
over again
oh man it would be heartbreaking I I
really don't know if I'd be able to
handle that
window
oh hi oh my God basement
oh no
you keep sweeping just keep sweeping
just keep sweeping sweep sweep sweep
just keep sweeping just keep sweeping
just keep sweeping sweeping
that really does throw me off
like when there's something it's so
monotonous until it's not in this rookie
I've been looking at you this whole damn
time key you cannot pull that one on me
the key is on the left side of the desk
if you're sitting at the desk on both of
the desks
both of them
what's probably even more important is
not to linger you can always come back
and look at it again with fresh eyes I
think I'm spouting as if I know what I'm
talking about once more
but you can always come back to it
feels like time's moving slower just
a second yes no yes it's not ringing any
bells it's not I'm trusting the shiver
down my spine
unless something causes me to go then
I don't trust shut up it's four o'clock
you cannot do this
what what
the bottom shelf of those were brighter
the
the books
this bottom shelf it was brighter
am I crazy
oh what the [__]
what is it
I have no [__] idea was something
else changed
oh I gotta keep moving don't dwell on it
don't dwell on it I don't know what I
got I don't know what happened I don't
know why it happened but it happened and
I got it I trusted the shiver down my
spine literally that time I felt like
something go oh something's not right
it's like that feeling that you're being
watched which is weird because I'm the
one doing the watching
but trust you whoa that ain't right I
don't even need to put a shiver down my
spine that that ain't right there but
trust your gut
your subconscious hind blizzard mine
knows it knows
it knows when something's up
hey there was something different about
that I have no idea lexian please pull
up two screenshots comparing the two and
then tell me what it was after the fact
[Music]
sweep technique really really works like
I'm I'm not lying this this is freaking
this is what lifeguards do I think I'm
pretty sure that because when lifeguards
are like looking for people drowning in
the middle of a crowded pool uh they
they train themselves to like sweep
wait
they trained themselves to sweep no no
no no no no no I'm on it no it's not an
emergency okay there's another there's
more anomalies here I don't know what
but there's more anomalies here okay uh
oh God what am I missing no no this is
the same it's the same there's only one
piece of paper it's not there it might
be in here I have not reported in here
I'm doing this because I got one burn
I'm betting it's in here I don't know
what it is
was it the door
the door doesn't seem right to me
oh it wasn't there what was it I didn't
catch what it was
the difference
all right Alexian please pull up a
screenshot and tell me what
something on right there
please tell me what the difference of
the other one was after the fact but
also don't get in the way in case I'm
I'm so close to winning this I can't
make one more wrong call but I'm gonna
trust my gut to the very end
if because if I don't have my gut to
trust then I don't have anything in life
I got nothing
their bad goal no more bad calls that
was two though that was two so whatever
it was that was different in here that I
did not see it worked
so I just need to be grateful for that
and hope that it doesn't happen again it
usually doesn't do the same anomaly
twice
oh wait I didn't burn one I thought I
burned one okay I'm okay there's two
stacks of money there top sweep bottom
sweep and I did get two this is the last
hour and there's going to be more
immediately I know there's more frick
something just shivered I just got the
shiver
I think there's an extra chair right
there
really smart and then I feel really dumb
but I am glad for the obvious ones okay
I've got to be ahead I've got to be out
of that because that was a long period
without one and then I did like five in
a row there
just gonna stay on top of it
same as you this one's pretty easy
because there's not much to there there
is a lot to this one so that would be a
reasonable one to just kind of throw all
right what the frick is wrong with you
yeah
get your eyeballs out of my painting
who's back there what Scooby-Doo villain
is back there
just gotta keep sweeping
weeping so well so far
right here at the end
see I don't know if that was I think
that was always like that but it also
looks slightly different so I don't
really know
okay that saves me trying to do one
there
okay
sweep just keep sweeping I want to stop
and linger but I cannot stop and linger
oh oh screw up what the hell is that hey
there was a piece of paper on there
wait was that just mirrored oh there's a
news down below whatever
okay that was good that was good that
was very good that was very good me
thank you me thank you me don't linger
don't linger
don't do it don't you do it don't you do
it don't pause don't stop by the floor
the floor is extremely different I
wouldn't even need to remember that that
is incredibly weird
yes thank you that's normal
to make it I'm going to make it I am
killing it I'm killing it 20 minutes
left and I'm done and I'm done so and
I'm done in rings
give me something easy
oh my God give me something easy
oh please give me something easy
oh my God I'm missing one I'm missing
one I don't know what but I'm missing
one I know I am Ah Holy cruel my God oh
my God oh my God hi
oh my God
that might have been the last one that I
needed that might carry me over the
threshold if I can just keep it together
for a little bit longer just a little
bit longer that's all I'm asking just a
little bit longer
oh well that's an easy one I'll take it
baby I'll take it ew is that
tryptophobia
oh I think I did it
I'm not gonna be stuck here for two and
a half hours
okay
one cup of coffee
nothing's jumping out of me maybe it was
the fan was it the fan
was it that the fan was off in there I
was so distracted by the visual of
everything that I totally forgot about
the audio cues there are audio cues in
some places but it don't even matter
baby
yes
oh my God
oh my God oh my God
oh 31.
oh
you were trying to kill me okay and with
that I'm done I'm not gonna go back I've
done it I don't need to see the school
in the Metro I don't need to do those
I'm done maybe if I'm bored on a live
stream Sunday down the road
I'll do that but honestly I'm done I'm
done I like not having to report the
type of the anomaly that makes it more
fun instead of trying to guess oh my God
oh my God so that works go don't linger
go faster see everything get the
normalcy in your head and let it just be
a feeling I still lost on the first try
but let it just be a feeling and then
you can get a better understanding of
what exactly well not exactly what
generally is different
I'm done thank you everybody so much for
watching and thank you for all the
patience in uh joining me on this
adventure hopefully it was fun for you
hopefully it was terrifying in some ways
if you saw something that I didn't how
long was that thing on the ceiling
I don't want to know thank you
and as always I will see you in the next
video
bye-bye